meghan markle is back in the news sorry
to say
meghan markle
the former duchess of sussex married
prince harry this american bio weapon
that was we probably built in a lab here
i wonder if dr fauci built meghan markle
in a lab on at the behest of the us
government to destroy the british royal
family because that's certainly what
she's been doing she uh we sent her over
there then they sent her back he said no
we don't want her
you can take harry too we don't want him
either so meghan markle
very very unlikable public figure
meghan markle comes out and has just
compared her
marrying into the royal family her
becoming an actual princess
to nelson mandela
being freed from prison
meghan markle has a new podcast because
every millennial has to have a podcast
that's a federal law now i think meghan
markle on her podcast claims that when
she attended the lion king in london
a cast member pulled her aside and just
said i need you to know
when you married into this family we
rejoiced in the streets
the same we did when mandela was freed
from prison
uh the grandson of nelson mandela the
south african leader uh did not like
this comment
from meghan markle understandably so
what does this tell you it tells you
that the victim narrative especially in
america
but throughout the western world but
especially in america
is so
so powerful i bet she believes it
i bet meghan markle one of the most
privileged people on earth
actual royalty
believes that she is a victim
like a political dissident
being imprisoned for years
that's it and the narrative is very very
strong
and so we cannot
we can either
complain about it or we can try to make
it work in our favor
okay donald trump actually did this
donald trump did not exactly take the
high road in 2016. he was attacked for
that i said donald you're just playing
the victim you're just crying and
complaining
you need to stop complaining donald and
what did trump say he said you know what
i'm going to do
i'm going to complain complain complain
complain complain complain complain i'm
going to wine wine wine wine wine until
i win
and what what trump i i don't know if
this was conscious or just subconscious
because the guy's got a good gut he was
saying i'm gonna play american politics
where it actually is
you're all gonna play american politics
where the bow tie set in the think tanks
over the fancy lunches wishes that it
were but me that's not what i'm going to
do i'm going to play american politics
right where it lives
i'm not going to present my case to the
american people in a series of white
papers when people ask donald trump hey
what are you going to do as president he
goes you know what i want i want great
neighborhoods
i want there to be great neighborhoods
okay that's that's going to be my job as
president and all the bow tie people and
all the think tank they said oh my gosh
no that's not what the role of the
federal government actually that what we
need to do is take that power out of
washington dc then send that back to the
states and the local government ideally
the county governments and then and you
know what the american people here the
sort of average voter here is uh
what shut up nerd
shut up nerd i hate my neighborhood
there's guns everywhere there's drugs on
the streets there's some bum defecating
on my sidewalk yeah i'm going to vote
for the guy that gives me a good
neighborhood thank you very much
no but actually you don't understand
because of the principle of federalism
you have no
no
and you know trump might understand that
as well i mean i'm i'm pro-federalism
i'm pro-restoring a coherent political
order
but we've got we got drugs everywhere
we've got the average life expectancy in
the united states declining we got
people chopping off the genitals of
little kids we've got crime going
through the roof so
forgive me if when we're campaigning and
talking to real human beings with real
problems and real concerns
we take it out of the pie in the sky for
a second and say oh yeah you see that
problem that problem in your life if you
elect me i'm going to do my very best to
fix it
that's what we got to do right now head
on over to ring.com
summer is busy it's busy for everyone
people go on vacation if you're me you
spend three days in the hospital because
your wife is giving birth to your second
beloved son either way you're going to
be away from home so you want to be able
to keep an eye on your home whether
you're there in the home whether you're
at the office whether you're on a beach
on the other side of the world ring can
do that you all know about the ring
video doorbell where you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door
wherever you are in the world did you
know that ring has an award-winning
alarm with available professional
monitoring when you subscribe well if
you didn't know that you certainly
should because then you can protect your
home you can keep an eye on your on your
windows on your doors on everything in
between but that's not all did you know
that ring has ring alarm pro that's what
cnet calls a giant leap for home
security where you protect not just your
physical home but your digital home too
well let's do it baby protect your
digital home with a very fast eero wi-fi
6 router become a pro be a pro just like
me this summer go pro get ring alarm pro
learn more at ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles as a video just went viral
it's actually captured on a ring
doorbell cam
of a guy a 22 year old guy
who
tries to bust into his ex-girlfriend's
house and the ex-girlfriend's living
with her family obviously they're pretty
young people and she says go away you
know no i'm not letting you in and he he
won't take no for an answer he just
starts trying trying to bust down the
door here's what happens
so door's locked
he starts just trying to shoulder it and
try and bust in through it
it's not happening
you hear the guy inside he goes i got a
gun get out of here doesn't matter he
keeps trying to bust in the door
and then the guy with the gun really had
a gun shoots the guy
the guy goes down the guy is dead
your first reaction to this video
will tell me everything i need to know
about your political views this video
it's a sad video i mean you don't you
don't really see the guy die on camera
mercifully but you see him he gets shot
he kind of stammers off the camera
if your first reaction to this video is
oh that that kid that poor kid oh no can
you hear this country we have too many
guns like that's so unnecessary they
didn't have to if that's your first
reaction then you're a lib then you're a
leftist then your view of justice is
just kind of messed up
your first take watching that video is
oh sad that the house
the the owner of the house had to do
that but he did what he had to do and he
protected his daughter then your view of
justice and politics is
going to be conservative and right-wing
and correct
and that's it and it
it tells me a lot about american
politics too because in on the way the
camera is set up right just by virtue of
it being a doorbell
all you see
is the guy who gets shot
so so you say well he must be the victim
he's not the victim he's the perpetrator
what the hell was he going to do to that
poor girl the girl in the house says dad
i think he's going to kill me what's he
getting
could you imagine you're you're in a
home you're saying i have a gun go away
stop trying to break into my home and
then the guy keeps coming in
i don't think that guy's there to talk i
don't think that guy's there to have tea
i think that guy's there to do bad bad
things
but the perspective here is everything
because a lot of people are looking at
that and they're going to say oh that
poor he's the victim they shouldn't the
the dad should have shot him in the leg
or whatever whatever nonsense that
people who've never held a firearm in
their lives say
the dad should have fired a warning shot
you know joe biden you should have fired
a shotgun into the air yeah that's a
good idea joe
but that's the perspective you don't you
don't see the camera's not on
the father who's defending his home and
his daughter the camera's not on the
daughter who the hell knows what that
guy has already done had already done or
would have done to that daughter
and that's it and that that perspective
is so key
and a really important rule for politics
that i would strongly recommend is that
we get a lot better about turning the
camera
okay when we the libs always talk about
how you know the poor victims
of the war on drugs you know the drug
dealers those poor victims
so it's so wrong that we lock up all the
drug dealers working for the mexican
cartels that's so terrible peddling
poison to little kids what what victims
they're they're not the victims they're
the perpetrators
the victims are the people who die
because some some
pill peddler you know gave them gave
them some drugs outside of their school
the victims are the family members of
the poor kids who die
the victims are the american people
where the average life expectancy goes
down you got to turn the camera you got
to turn the perspective a little bit
the the issue with victim culture is not
even that
there are no such thing as victims it's
that the people who are pretending to be
victims are usually the perpetrators in
victim culture and maybe if we paid a
little more attention to the actual
victims we'd be a lot better off it's
kind of like cancel culture problem with
cancer culture is not that we have
standards and we say you can and can't
say certain things it's that in in our
current cancer culture
if if you say the truth you'll get
canceled and if you say false things
false things you'll get promoted that's
actually what my uh
kind of video essay on youtube is about
where we have all the receipts and we
talk about the social media
blacklist campaign that went on for two
and a half years that's the issue the
issue is not that we cancel people it's
that we cancel good things and promote
bad things when really it should be
the opposite
i'm glad you like that clip now hold on
you got to ring that bell ring that bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you